[Music]
we by the power of the eternal heaven
con of the great you loose our command
[Music]
this is a version sent to the great Pope
that he may know and understand in the
Muslim tongue what has been written the
petition of the assembly held in the
lands of the Emperor for our support has
been heard from your emissaries if he
reaches you with his own report thou who
art the great Pope together with all the
princes come in person to serve us at
that time I shall make known all the
commands of the Yasir you have also said
that supplication and prayer have been
offered by you that I might find a good
entry into baptism this prayer of thine
I have not understood other words which
thou has sent me I am surprised that
thou has seized all the lands of the
Magyar and the Christians tell us what
their fault is these words of thine I
have also not understood the eternal God
has slain and annihilated these lands
and people because they have neither
adhered to Chinggis Khaan nor to the car
GaN both of whom have been sent to make
known God's command nor to the command
of God like thy words they also were
impede n't they were proud and they slew
our messenger emissaries how could
anybody sees or kill by his own power
contrary to the command of God
though thou likewise says that I should
become a trembling nestorian christian
worship God and be an ascetic how
knowest thou whom God absolves in truth
to whom he shows mercy how does thou
know that such words as thou speakest
are with God's sanction from the rising
of the Sun to its setting all the lands
have been made subject to me who could
do this
contrary to the command of God now you
should say with a sincere heart I will
submit and serve you
thou thyself at the head of all the
princes come at once to serve and wait
upon us at that time I shall recognize
your submission if you do not observe
God's command and if you ignore my
command I shall know you as my enemy
likewise I shall make you understand if
you do otherwise God knows what I know
[Music]
you